friends deal breakers is someone who
doesn't have a j o yeah someone who
doesn't have a job is have job you don't
have a
job why you got to scream like a gor
Gore my you called her Garo that's crazy
I've actually worn the male version of a
dress whatever they're called like hi hi
nice to meet you nice to meet you nice
to meet you my name is waen a lot of
people are are interested in outer space
and I'm interested in Inner Space okay
tell me
more let me get some
water I think I need to drink for this
one I think we going to have some
alcohol you you did
you did all all that for that
in in a
space inner thing your box them yeah
tush people look they see space and the
Stars they see all this stuff and
they're like really turned on by it and
I'm kind of disgusted by the negligence
of out the use of money PR
space uh how's your weekend been so far
I've been pretty good I celebrated my f
best friend's birthday yesterday oh
Taurus okay I saw a murder last night
okay attempted murder I was filming a
video in California and I saw a man get
shot in the neck and now we're trying to
sell it to a news station it's
absolutely batshit crazy
yeah
okay how's your day oh you know I took
out my dog out for work great I watched
the genocide
happen I think she's weirded out by
me so why did you press on me I
immediately I knew you were not
interested right off right off the bat
just because you thought that I wasn't
interested that's why you didn't want to
continue conversation yeah I mean I'm
trying to get married and have like 100
kids so like why was other's time I
respect that I hope you have fun on your
next day thank
you what's your name I'm Ida I'm
Dominique nice to meet you nice to meet
you so how old are you I'm 26 how old
are you I'm 32 what are you two looking
for in a relationship right now I'm a
I'm a tender person man I need somebody
to be tender with me man I used to be
out in the streets was you a hoe never
been I never been I don't got a large
number what about
you but she asked the question yo I was
in these streets you were a [__]
and he went uh no don't say it like that
I wasn't like a high number want someone
same as you like kind of like caring but
also like grow together just don't be on
your suck [__] like I really just don't
like that kind of stuff I've met grown
ass men that are children if you're a
child don't [__] with me I mean how do
you how much do you understand what they
going through if you're in a predicament
where you're trying M that's not I will
never jump that but if you're a person
who chooses to sit on your ass MH and be
in home all [__] day while someone's
working oh I can't find J cuz you're
just looking on your phone no get up off
your ass do some [__] you can find other
jobs like you know like work through it
go ahead that's fine and that's not
that's and I'll tell you why I did it I
think that you have to come to a term of
forgiving people for not being their
best selves and that's not me thinking
you having Ida was that
surprising yeah I kind of liked you a
little bit anyways nice to meet you
that's it talk about what was your name
again Yaya
okay
cool when I come up up in this Che
didn't being a toal ass
ho got you on a check when you come in
then this [__] and come with disrespect
wo bust that sick out here I wouldn't
cat call anybody you would what I
wouldn't cat call I've never catall
somebody but if some girls walking by me
and she goes my name is Yaya I'm like
y
that's not cat calling okay that's just
a buster Rhymes that's
calling s that's so
childish but yeah I like y y it's a
beautiful man no M would be uh I like
the water I like to look at the water do
you wake board or wake surf or okay I
just like to like would you try it I
would yeah okay yeah I'm down to bust my
ass I don't know if the Box wants to say
it but I don't really like city girls
city girls okay like the stipulations
that come along with that is is kind of
dumb like a New York City girl like no
no like what okay so what do you mean so
City girl City girl is kind of like no
that's not what
I how yeah you can't be using hip-hop
references with people that casually
okay yeah it's not everybody that's on
the same level I'm one of the city boys
oh yeah I love going to the city
mainlands amazing I'm just not about
that Thug Life yeah we don't like
criminals here either no no I mean I
ain't about that all right there we go
okay so what do you mean you so City
girl City girl is kind of like uh fly me
out do this do this do this like I'm
sorry why why is that a they don't she's
like wait what yeah I want to see her
confusion this is like when red pill
people meet normal people and they like
a high value man can cheat like what the
[__] are you talking about this is this
moment let me just let me is that a city
girl like it's not that not just that
let me finish uh like the intentions is
not to actually get to know you just
have this standard that is not
understanding
okay I felt like this came out of
nowhere the girl's like do you like
wakeboarding would you be down he like
yeah I'm down to try and new stuff and
he's just out of nowhere brought up like
I don't know if the Box wants to say it
but I don't really like city
girls did that not come out of nowhere
hey she looks confused too yeah cuz he
kind of came out of know he's like I
don't want to be with a gold digger it's
like and and and she still doesn't
understand that refence is City girl she
doesn't know hipop so she thinks that he
thinks that he women from the city are
gold diggers hey yo hold there's levels
to this [__] but yeah you didn't get it
some of these people live online so much
or they don't interact with other
communities that they don't know how to
talk about this stuff like there's some
deep cut stuff when it comes to hip-hop
lingo that I wouldn't use with a casual
and then be surprised when they don't
get it you feel me like there's just
certain things you you're not going to
say like if I'm talking to somebody I'm
like yo they're trying to catch the fade
and they're like like a
haircut but even it's not everybody that
that's going to know a fade is related
to a haircut so they're not even going
to get that you know what I mean but
even in the other people the other
person that he was with the why did you
buzz me answer was about money didn't
even match no but it was also about the
whole money thing like remember when he
asked for forgiveness what did she have
to forgive she had to forgive the guys
who weren't ambitious and now again once
again the
whole weird
weird I'm nice to meet you nice to meet
you too
so Adrian says the only reason not to
date him is the size of
his apartment apartment my apartment is
270 ft it's a little small bed's a twin
but uh you know you have a bathroom yes
and I have inunit washer dryer have a
stove everything W and I have 70 pairs
of shoes in there so see I don't have a
problem with him having that apartment
in it's super small size do do what you
got to do to survive you have [__]
grills throw yourself off a bridge
what's wrong with grills no it's nothing
wrong with grills there's something
wrong with grills when you have a 275t
apartment yeah priorities my [__]
there's something very wrong with that
you got a Mercedes b but you can't
afford a real Studio no I would give her
reaction if I meet a girl and she got a
Chanel bag but she live in a [__]
bedroom with no bathroom she a
room yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the red flag not the strug hi
quick reminder we have a Discord join it
I'm in
there you know it's all fitting do you
um I guess like have you been dating
like are you a Serial
dater Fu you two went hard tell each
other tell me why I don't know I just
wasn't giv the vibe yeah I wasn't giving
you the vi I just I just wasn't there it
was his grills
yeah was nice me ni I don't mind people
blinging out don't be a broke [__]
blinging out that's stupid that's like
putting [__] diamonds on a doooo
stain that's what I said diamonds on a
doooo that's what I said and you know
it's kind of true Diamond the do think
about it that's funny it's like girls
telling you they if the bomb is head
they out here advertising they got
tongue piercing and come to find the
bedroom they like I don't suck come to
me with a tongue piercing and she don't
suck that yo that's a fight not
physically
[Music]
spiritually hey watch out someone's
going to clip this yeah yeah yeah
spiritual warfare you know so I was just
saying grills and you live in that 200
I'm aside with the ladies no if if I
don't want to cuz I'm red pill on the
inside but I'm aside with the ladies
somebody got to be R if if you if if you
if you rocking grills and you can do
this in your apartment and you stretched
out every wall that wall to wall and
that's that yeah if you on like Chris
Brown Wall to Wall that's a good song I
don't see what nothing but ladies called
okay what's
up I like that song I'm not going to lie
I can see that you don't like that song
it's all right you got the vampires they
trying to Thriller [__] it's not really
Thriller but it's it was like w to
wow but L it was kind of a like Back
Street Boys Back Street back all right
my version yeah I love it when Chris
Tred to belt out the vocals but he
really can't but he trying and it's not
bad you got vocals I don't see nothing
but ladies I'm like bro you can't really
hit them notes but I appreciate the
effort though this [__] still fly like
Chris is a good performer he's a good
music maker he got that voice you think
Chris ain't got that voice yeah ain't
got that voice are you
serious yeah ain't got that voice he
ain't got that kind of I think you got
that voice excuse me sir I heard you
from across the room even was not
talking to us sir listen I didn't want
to misgender you mis preach [__] is
wrong with you bro I don't want to
misgender you you're looking for a fight
a fight yeah a fight what do you mean I
said sir and then you're the one who
corrected me so I can say Miss but the
song the song is not certain you're not
talking to me and you're not singing
that song to me pause okay canot I it's
okay I think it's okay to sing to
another man as long as it's mainly
lyrics excuse me sir like that's fine
yeah cuz what you saw me across the room
hey I did yo what's wrong with seeing
somebody across anyways yo you saw
another [__] from across the room what
huh yeah I did so why were you staring
from that fall he's
weird he's weird I'm hey hey he's weird
hold up it's not me leave a comment
below fellas have you guys never seen a
dude from across the that is not the
question my guy that is not the question
have you guys never seen a fella from
across the that is not that's not the
like have you thought of it you're not
going to do you're not going to do
that do do
yay
girl
girl no no no no dude he's been a whole
ass weird right now that's the question
not tell me ladies have you seen him and
must
have it must have been five minutes hi
what's your name Adrien adri me you
what's your name jayen it's like alien
with the J right yes probably the first
time you heard it huh no because I tell
everyone that oh really I know I work at
Geico I'm like a clean trainer oh so you
could teach me about insurance I could
teach you about insurance I know all
about insurance I want you to teach her
about insurance in a sexy voice oh my in
a sexy voice man you know you got a
scenario scenario someone get hit by a
car now what someone call you hey
someone hit my car I think she's crazy
like I think this dude's weird but I
think this girl she giving me crazy
energy do what's the next step
dang okay I'd be like damn someone hit
your car I really car I
really yeah that was the opposite of sex
that was not it was not it that was
goria for the ears oh wow just don't
have a
sex the laugh I'm telling you be the
laugh you beef the L bro yo you know
what it is is some people don't have a
filter between like their brain and
their mouth and everything just blurs
out yeah and that to me is like the
Shire way to know somebody crazy these
[__] are are straight pipe what
you mean straight pipe oh okay straight
pipe is whenever you have an engine and
you want to have less restriction to
your engine you remove the catalic uh
catalytic inverter and it it goes
straight from one the muffler goes from
your engine straight out so we get all
the noise but because it has a muffler
and the original Muffler you don't hear
that all right thank you but that
[__] ain't got no muffler on
she's not even a straight pipe is engine
out doesn't have a job is have a job you
don't have a
job bmbo
[Music]
CLI BM ass
CLS deal breakers someone who doesn't
have a j o yeah someone who doesn't have
a job is have a job you don't have a job
why you got to scream like a g Gore
my called gargoyle that's crazy but the
scream though that's crazy why the [__]
you got that was a dope ass show back in
the days you watch that show watch
they're going to do a live action I'm
Elizabeth Elizabeth I'm Adrian nice to
meet you I always like to ask people
this question I know it's super random
but would you choose that dress is
really nice I don't know what it is so I
I think I'm a sucker for
dresses I think I'm a sucker for dresses
a girl could be a five she rolling with
a dress she go up to like a seven you
know what it is what is it is when they
walk in the ass Chee
go it's partially that it's partially
that it's just something about a dress
is just El oh there's something about
that
yeah there's something about that it's
also nice when you ain't got to take off
their clothes to [__] him you just have
to hike him up that [__] kind of fire
too this is something about like wench
you like
[__] fantasies yeah yeah yeah yeah
definitely ignore me Mo death Mo de I've
actually worn the male version of a
dress whatever they're called like in
Arabic countries you know how the males
work we robes jalabia
uh I have one of those and when you're
not wearing underwear them shits is the
best like like if you've never felt the
wind on your
balls I'm serious I'm serious don't
laugh like as man a lot of us don't know
that feeling when you get a breeze go
like that [__] hit different women get
to experience that cuz they have you
know well a lot of them depend on the
dress they'll still wear some but a lot
of them don't it's freeing yeah feels
amazing I know I used to wear KS it's
like if you've never been bald you'll
never understand what it's like to have
the scalp and the wind make contact is
is the first time like losing your
virginity in a different way it's the
first time that you shave in a long time
and you spend like 30 minutes going like
this
yay yeah you like oh this is me this me
too yeah this me oh [__] me I see Baler
[__] sometimes complaining but I'm
like yo you get that wind touch though
yeah that [__] hit
different like you have someone
caressing you all the time like you
might not get no cuddles from women but
nature cuddling you be like baby it's
going to be okay we might have taken
your hair but we going to give you some
of this mhm that feels nice kind of
feels nice so my balding fans we
watching right now you good you got
something in your corner you got a
special experience with nature we call
that wind
therapy yeah yeah go outside just be
standing on a [__] Bridge be like
this do you imagine just like [__] yeah
do you imagine just like 40 bald [__]
just standing on the bridge like this
I I see it people are like yo what is
this cult ceremony yes you you can't get
it you don't get it it's okay if you
don't get it walk off youall deserve it
I always like to ask people this
question I know it's super random but
would you choose waffles or pancakes oh
waffles which one you choose [__] shut
the [__] up and let me eat but which one
you have to pick you I don't have to
pick [__] you got waffles it's going to
be that it's going to be pancake it's
going to be that I don't care but if
they have both I don't care what can you
make the fastest that's that's a nothing
question I don't care really I do not
care I'mma probably say pancakes a good
pancake is just always going to be
better than a good waffle good I you
know is one of them things especially
when you start putting in some chocolate
chips in that maple syrup it just hit
different for waffles I guess if you
like putting weird [__] on waffles like
chicken then maybe you like that but
outside of that I feel like waffles are
100% inferior no I'm I'm whatever who
cares what you think you don't like
eggs but you asked so I don't give a
[__] either yeah yeah but it's not like
I cared I just ass but then you want to
be all difficult difficult so I'm like
difficult difficult I don't care yeah I
can tell you care me not it's me not
being difficult excuse me sir I saw you
from across Oh my days I love waffles
pancakes I don't know they're not as
fluffy they don't have the nice fluff to
them I feel like pancakes are fluffier
than waffles what are you talking about
it's like I'm not going to I'm not going
to I'm not going to argue over pancakes
like no I'm going to waste my energy on
some other [__] but you're not a
breakfast person like that so you don't
get it that's not I'm not a breakfast
you don't sound like a bre you don't
like like eggs you don't care between
pancakes and waffles you've already
killed 90% of breakfast what's left go
ahead fruits [__] are you a fruits
person for veggies for for breakfast I'm
a whatever person for breakfast then
you're not a breakfast person yo
breakfast people right now in the chat
oh yeah breakfast people rally shut the
[__] up with that [__] yeah breakfast
people go in the chat right now uh to
the breakfast resore like nah nah that's
the the yo breakfast unite what the [__]
are you doing how you going to say you
like
breakfast how you going to say you like
that's not even a thing how you going to
say you like breakfast but you don't
like eggs you don't care about waffles
or or pancakes you're not about it it's
okay it's okay nobody gives a [__] it's
okay [__] weirdo you like those non
nerds who always want to be claiming
nerds it's not true I don't give a [__]
too cool I just want to eat exct it's
not a question it's not a question about
yo if if I just want to eat and I'm not
going to argue with with a person over
breakfast and pancake eat what you want
to eat I'mma eat and I just want to
dance but guess what right now we got a
job to
do what we are talk to do so yeah yeah
and you I just want to dance no no and
you went I just want to dance what the
[__] is that I just want to dance what
the [__] is that my guy I don't know
what's in them bottles over there you've
been drinking
okay but it's affecting your
brain all right
let's good I feel like the Romantic
chemistry like just isn't there for me I
feel that for sure yeah cool well thank
you yeah good mece meet you what are you
looking for right now Elizabeth low key
low key not a not a white dude in
grills I be honest you not anybody in
grills but especially not a white dude
in grills it looks weird it's like
seeing a white dude in a doag can you
yes should you no what tarnation
sometimes I see a white girl in a kimono
and I'm just like do you know anything
about Japanese no like can you sure
should you I
mean you know did you say neow that's
Chinese but yeah you did you say niow no
I was I trying to say noow no no you
know like you know like a cat stop
calling me out leave me alone
a husband I'm at a point in life where I
really want to meet like someone special
as spend life with hi hi I'm Max I'm
Elizabeth nice to meet you Elizabeth I
love your hair thank you it's beautiful
and your are also really great thank you
so much fun fact about Max he has sold
video games to MTV and Nickelodeon like
ones that you created yeah yeah in high
school I made like the flash games that
you know you'd play in like the librar
and made like 10 to
$4,000 my junior year yeah Elizabeth
wants to get married she's ready to
settle down have kids well I I don't
want kids like now now but like in four
or five years fair fair so wa when are
you looking to get married though that's
my question is there like a specific
timeline or I don't want to like rush
anything so no Wedding Bells next year
then unless it work probably not that
would be a little insane I've lit up red
a few times nobody's proud of me you you
V yeah I'm having fun I think you're
pretty cool I'm going to light out red
one more time if you don't press me I'm
going to consider it a
[Music]
match she stops here cuz I actually
pre-at this and she asks him pancakes
were shut the [__] up and his answer you
guys are going to be really
disappointed his chicken his
waffles
she's going to reject him why am I
spoiling
this cuz I don't like you
[__]
W it's love there's going to be Wedding
Bells of the year I predict it I'm never
wrong you get out of here you two you
two little love birds all right they
found love how' you how how you feel
about uh how do you feel about today's
episode um n whatever just like pancakes
and waffles and breakfast and general
for you cuz you don't care about
breakfast cuz you're not a breakfast
person got you what did you what did you
feel about the
episode Pancakes that's what he feels
honestly there was a couple moments
where you kind of drive me crazy and I
just want to be and I wanted to do that
was that was on a fun moment you know
what I mean that was a lot that was on a
fun thing yeah that was a lot in front
of someone you don't know yeah ble they
was doing too much no that's it all all
right anyways that's it for today's
episode let's know what you guys think
in the comments below